[Music]
and eMac first came on the screen in
2017 and we couldn't be more grateful
but did you hear that this show is
forever changing the Disney Channel wait
until you hear about all the issues this
incredible show touches on don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to the things now let's check
out how Angie Mac has changed the Disney
Channel the show
Andy Mac is about a story of a character
coming of age or better yet we should
say all characters because every single
person in the series faces a different
problem kids today might relate to the
show is all about self-discovery and
each episode touches on an important
problem
modern teenagers might face in today's
world the cast includes Peyton Elizabeth
Leigh Asher Angel Joshua Rush Sophia
Wylie Lilian Bowden and many more the
series first aired in 2017 and as of
March 2018 it featured two seasons while
the first season definitely wasn't
talked about the show left an important
mark in Disney's history
Andy Mac definitely faced plenty of
criticism from those that think children
today shouldn't be exposed to such
issues but the show has also been
praised by parents and those who know
very well about the struggles teenagers
might face in today's world the
characters and Emax characters are
complex and come with layers of issues
that go beyond the typical Disney
characters traits and personalities
without giving away too many spoilers
for you we'll just talk about the things
that you should definitely know along
with going with the unusual plot in
which one of the characters sisters is
actually the mother Andy Mack has been
praised for his progressive thinking for
example the character known as Cyrus was
the very first Disney character to come
out as gay we'll talk more about that
later but we also want to focus on
someone else because there's an Andy
Mack character that pays a tribute to
one of the greatest Vampire Slayer's of
all time yep it's Buffy while Buffy the
Vampire Slayer might have ended years
ago the iconic name of one of our
favorite characters lives on Andy max
the even stated that she got named after
the Vampire Slayer although we have a
feeling it'll be extremely hard to fill
in the cool shoes that were once worn by
the original Buffy it's important to
note this adorable tribute so why is
this show changing Disney Channel well
for one because Disney never touched on
the coming on issue so directly while
there might have been plenty of
subliminal messages that could have been
directed at the LGBT youth and Emax
characters have made history by
addressing one of the most important
things LGBTQ teens face today
Cyrus even talks to Buffy about feeling
different and weird
- which Buffy replies that he has always
been weird just never different they're
comforting words are words that many
LGBTQ teens need to hear touching on
issues like this gives this particular
Disney show a brand new meaning for many
and shows that they are finally getting
to know their demographic in the past a
lot of Disney shows focused on
presenting the struggles teens face
every day but they were always
one-dimensional and never touched on
sexuality and since teenagers often know
about their sexuality from a young age
it's extremely important to have a
Disney show that finally addresses these
issues and show support but Andy Mack
isn't only as support for the LGBT youth
the show also touches an area that isn't
really talked about much and that is
military families in the story Buffy's
mother returns home from the military
and the story itself even resonated with
the actress that plays Buffy as her
father was part of a military family
when the episode was first screened the
cast had the privilege of doing a
private screening with military families
in New York this shows the importance
that no matter what your story is it's
meant to be heard whether your family
circumstances are different from others
or whether you as a person feel like
you're different from others your story
is meant to be listened to and most
importantly it highlights the fact that
whatever you might be going through
you're never alone there's even more to
it coming-of-age might look different in
different cultures and religions which
is why Andy Mack awesome highlights the
Jewish culture as one of the characters
has a Bar Mitzvah even the cast's are
able to draw from their own stories
Joshua rush who plays Cyrus was able to
use some of his personal items during
that bar mitzvah episode including a
tallit that was given to him by his
grandparents
Disney might not have a really bright
past when it comes to educating kids on
religion but we have a feeling their
sense of humor might have shifted in a
completely different direction with Andy
Mack critical acclaim
Andy Mac has an impressive score of 88
percent on Rotten Tomatoes
and has so far been nominated once for
outstanding kids and family programming
with the coming out story in season two
premiere and Emax reputation reached
brand new heights the season 2 premiere
increased the viewership by an
impressive 72 percent and was seen by
1.1 million kids aged between 6 and 14
the story is praised as it represents
the lives of the LGBTQ youth around the
country as well as around the world
given the popularity of the show this
might mean that Disney will finally
start paying attention to the social
issues kids face in everyday life and
produce more content that might change
people's lives season three with the
popularity of season two the show has of
course been renewed for the third season
but before the launch of the third
season the show will air season two B
which should appear on screens in summer
of 2018 season 3 will reportedly be
aired in late 2018 or early 2019 not
much has been revealed on the plot and
storyline of the next season but we have
a feeling the team behind Andy Mac will
work hard to make sure that the
heartwarming stories they feature still
resonate with whatever the teenagers are
facing in their everyday life and we
feel like we definitely won't be
disappointed considering what we have
seen so far and that's all for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the thanks
and tell us how you felt about this
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]